favoriser les économies d'énergie dans
les bâtiments c'est l'un des objectifs
de la loi de transition énergétique des
dispositifs des aides existent pour en
savoir plus c'est bien j'accueille 20 en
maths je vous propose dans un premier
temps de regarder un exemple avec la
tour bagatelle à dijon elle fait partie
donc des bâtiments anciens
à partir de janvier prochain si de gros
travaux de rénovation sont engagés il
faudra aussi faire des travaux
d'isolation thermique c'est ce que
prévoit la loi royal comme je vous le
disais regardez tout de suite ce
reportage
car si vous voulez des sensations percée
au 12e étage d'une tour qui en compte 16
c'est toujours avec le même
émerveillement que gilberte contemple sa
vue et pourtant son emménagement ne date
pas d'hier c'est à la création de la
tour il y à 60 ans quel venus
s'installer ici avec son mars c'était à
notre portée mais c'était nouveau et
puis l'occasion d'habiter clash yale à
l'époque la tour bagatelle est synonyme
de modernité
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus vraiment le
cas le syndic envisage des travaux
donnent des signes de fatigue
c'est pas un immeuble de standing
mais ce qu'ils veulent faire c'est quand
même une rénovation moderne
parmi les travaux envisagés le
ravalement de la façade une opération
coûteuse qui le fera encore plus dès le
1er janvier 2017 avec l'entrée en
vigueur de la loi royal elle impose des
travaux d'isolation lorsque des
modifications importants sont réalisés
sur une façade ou un toit et dont fait
grimper la facture et grincer les dents
des copropriétaires une problématique
bien connue chez sonia cette association
conseil syndic est propriétaire ici on
note les hésitations sont souvent dues à
un manque d'information sur les aides et
les subventions qu'à partir du moment où
une copropriété isolé par l'extérieur
chaque copropriétaire occupants à loin
un crédit d'impôt de 30% sur la
fourniture et la pose de l'isolant
donc très souvent cette thèse ne
serait-ce que cette première aide de
l'état peut permettre de couvrir
l'isolant la plus-value un peu value
liée à la mise en place de l'isolant un
gain énergétique à long terme mais une
décision plus difficile à prendre
espérons que cette loi ne soit pas un
frein à la rénovation et n'entraînent
pas plus de face à terme dans nos rues
est un frein à la rénovation n'ont pas
forcément là quand même de bons côtés
dans le sens où on va pas s'amuser à
maintenant à faire des ravalements de
façade pour faire du cache-misère sert
d'ailleurs on va avoir un vrai impact
après j'ai envie de vous dire qu'on ne
va pas faire une rénovation n'importe
comment
c'est à dire qu'il ya quand même des
procédures à avoir et on va pas
m'appliquer n'importe quel matériau sur
n'importe quel bâtiment par exemple
par exemple on va éviter d'appliquer un
matériau qui va avoir du mal à respirer
comme le polystyrène sur une maison en
pierres anciennes
on va plutôt partir sur des matériaux
isolants mais respirant qui plein de
bois ou laine de verre est ce qu'elle
est les professionnels sont sont
suffisamment informés et professionnels
compétents pour pouvoir répondre à ces
nouvelles demandes finalement maintenant
oui puisque si vous voulez la
réglementation impose que l'entreprise
sont reconnues r j'ai eu donc reconnu
garant de l'environnement pour pouvoir
bénéficier des différentes aides de
l'état type crédit d'impôt alors
différentes aides de l'état dont il ya
des crédits d'impôts comment je peux
réussir à pouvoir en bénéficier alors
crédit d'impôt éligibles à tous on va
pas voir des différences au niveau des
revenus c'est-à-dire vous faites des
travaux d'économie d'énergie par exemple
vous isolez votre toiture
vous avez pris une entreprise r j'ai eu
sur la facture théoriquement
l'entreprise est censé vous donner le
montant éligible au crédit d'impôt vous
donner ce montant là aux impôts et ça
vous donne directement 30% sur votre
année précédente
le fait que ce soit maintenant
obligatoire à partir du 1er janvier 2017
ne relève pas du tout le fait qu'on
puisse avoir des aides alors non pas du
tout vous pouvez avoir d'autres est
autre que le crédit d'un pour vous
pouvez avoir les aides de l'anah donc de
l'état l'agencé signe de l'amélioration
de l'habitat
pour cela il faut s'organiser enfin il
faut venir vers les différents
organismes compétents dont saulire vous
pouvez avoir le droit à tout ce qui est
certificats d'économie d'énergie mis en
place par ce qu'on appelle des obligés
type tous les distributeurs d'énergie
df angie total carrefour auchan mais
attention j'insiste bien que toutes les
démarches de l'été avant la réalisation
des travaux c'est très incertain
il est important justement dans quel
sens on s'y prend on vient vous voir on
prend déjà des renseignements fait faire
un devis parce que alors j'ai envie de
vous dire que c'est en fonction du type
d'habitat quand on reprend l'exemple de
la tour bagatelle anciens voilà
bâtiments anciens et surtout bâtiment
propriété
il faut d'abord faire un état des lieux
c'est à dire que là moi je vous engage
plus à aller voir un bureau d'étude ou
l'espace info énergie au préalable pour
pouvoir voir qu'est ce qui a été fait
durant les dernières années
qu'est-ce qu'elles sont les meilleurs
moyens pour améliorer au mieux la
rénovation thermique ensuite venir vers
les différents organismes qui peuvent
vous aider à monter de cette subvention
parce qu'un de ses subventions
malheureusement ça prend un peu de temps
on y réfléchit c'est un projet c'est de
l'investissement
donc on vient voir une association qui
va faire un autre bilan mais plus ciblée
aux particuliers dire qu'un audit
énergétique va prendre l'ensemble de la
tour bagatelle et nous on va venir pour
voir par exemple la dame qu'on a vu tout
à l'heure
derrière on va faire faire des devis
puisque ça embête toujours de faire
faire différents devis embêter les
entreprises après derrière nous on va
revenir vers l'on va leur dire bah
écoute et dont il ya ça qui nous manque
et ça qui nous manque et c'est ça qui
nous manque au moins attendre qu'on soit
venu qu'on fasse un listing de tous
qu'il faut bien avoir sur les devis et
ensuite commencé la prospection vous
avez dit que ça prend du temps
combien de points il faut s'y prendre à
la vente alors j'ai envie au moins six
mois pourquoi puisque en fonction des ja
de l'état des lieux qu'on trouve des
différentes solutions pour être éligible
aux différentes aides de faire appel à
des devis d'euros modifier les devis et
ensuite de déposer sa aux différents
financeurs ça peut prendre un peu de
temps à avoir le couteau sous le nom
tout à fait généralement en matière
d'isolation thermique quelles sont les
questions les plus récurrentes des
personnes qui vient de vous voir alors
les première question c'est qu'est-ce
qui est le plus efficace chez moi alors
généralement les gens vont me dire ah
bah oui les fenêtres c'est la première
chose à faire
oui et non tout dépend encore une fois
de l'habitat c'est à dire dans un
appartement effectivement les fenêtres
vont apporter un grand poste quand on
est sur une autre maison ça va pas être
forcément la priorité à faire sera
plutôt d'isoler tout d'abord les combles
les murs pensez également à ventiler
puisque éviter éviter le phénomène de
de cloche d'air en fait pour éviter ben
voilà que les murs pourrissent derrière
et que l'habitat soit sans merci
toutes ces explications et puis donc
vous pouvez vous rendre dans
l'association so dia pour avoir des
explications précises cas par cas et
j'ajoute aussi que pendant le mois de la
rénovation qui dure jusqu'au 30 novembre
la région et l'ademe de bourgogne
franche comté vous propose près de 50
rendez vous gratuit pour vous
accompagner dans votre projet de
rénovation merci